this video is brought to you by
curiositystream
[Music]
what's up guys helen here to talk about
something we collectively hate
and yet continue to gluttonously indulge
in election season
you know that special time when everyone
bombards you with digital ads pleading
emails annoying surveys
and inexplicably real paper mail all to
convince you to vote for their choice of
fancy suited whitetooth candidate
now elections are a necessity for any
functioning democracy
but nowhere in the constitution does it
mandate that the media spend two full
calendar years
pumping america's homes full of
speculation about likability
electability presidentialness and so
very occasionally
policy issues in fact it kind of makes
us freaks on the world stage
canadians consider 11 weeks to be a long
election cycle
while in france campaigning can't last
more than two weeks before the first
round of voting
which is to say the contemporary
american presidential election bonanza
is not the norm for the world so how did
we get here
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on american presidential elections
what happened and if you liked our deep
dive into the history of american
elections
then you should check out curiosity
stream curiosity stream is home to
thousands of non-fiction
documentary and movie titles about
science nature
food technology travel and you guessed
it history their different series cover
all eras of american history
and last night i checked out jfk back in
fable
it's a fascinating look at the mythos
behind jfk's iconic presidency
and examines why he remains such a
powerful figure in american culture
i can't wait to check out everything
else they have to offer and if you want
to see for yourself then you should
click the link in the description now
if you use the code wisecrack you can
get a whole year for just 14.99
that's less than two dollars a month for
thousands of hours worth of content
you can stream it all right on your
phone laptop smart tv and even your xbox
so check it out today
that's curiositystream.comwisecrack and
use the code wisecrack at checkout
thanks to curiositystream for sponsoring
this episode
and now back to the show and now we
gotta talk about a
major political heavyweight you know
president william henry harrison
okay okay he's not exactly the sexiest
name in politics
if you know him at all it's because he
kicked the bucket almost immediately
after becoming president
there's william henry harrison i died in
30 days
but his short-lived tenure in the white
house was made possible by a pretty
radical decision he campaigned that's it
that's the radical decision william
henry harrison campaigned for the
presidency
it sounds totally bananas but for the
first 100 years of american history
it was pretty taboo for a presidential
candidate to publicly try to become
president
no really as richard j ellis and mark
dedrick explain
for close to a hundred years the
prevailing norm was that the presidency
was
not an office one should actively seek
this precedent dated back to 1789
when george washington very reluctantly
accepted the gig
after a unanimous vote by the young
country's electors
after years of war and presumably bad
food all this tired general wanted was
to chill at home
instead he humbly accepted the call of
duty the men who angled to succeed him
somewhat followed his example modestly
accepting their party's nomination
before disappearing from public view
until the results were in of course this
stuffy propriety was undoubtedly a
performance
if you were thomas jefferson for
instance you wouldn't campaign so much
as casually sort of bribe someone to
start a newspaper purely for the
purposes of roasting your opponents
while publicly campaigning for president
wasn't cool it never stopped tons of
candidates like andrew jackson or
abraham lincoln from stealthily
controlling their
campaigns behind the scenes but asking
people to vote for you directly
that was just kind of tacky you weren't
supposed to be too greedy for power
explain scholar michael kazan even the
presidential embodiment of the tasmanian
devil
andrew jackson was convinced by his
advisors to let up on his letter-writing
campaign
and agreeably keep silent when running
for re-election
don't get me wrong there were still
campaigns throughout the century
surrogates and supporters of candidates
would do the dirty work of actually
rousing voters
but as scholar jeffrey tullis puts it
candidates exemplified a public teaching
that political campaigns were beneath
the dignity of men suited for governance
as land ownership requirements were
abolished newly eligible voters
that is landless white dudes wanted to
know who the hell they were voting for
this created a tension where candidates
wanted to be appropriately dignified
while also telling average joes what
they thought
enter my man harrison who ignited what
scholar kathleen hall jameson calls the
presidency's first full-blown campaign
in 1840. harrison was a military man but
his record was a bit spotty
when he first ran for president as a
whig in 1836
he orchestrated a tour through four
states where he was met with horse-drawn
carriage parades
bonfires and singing it gave ostensibly
a political speeches about the
importance of the declaration of
independence and
inoffensive patriotic stuff still dude
lost
but things were going to get real wild
in 1840. that's when harrison once again
tried for the presidency
this time at least pretending to be
intent on maintaining the basic decorum
washington had shown by
staying the hell home after all he had
explained where he stood
on everything in 1836 right tell that to
the democratic newspapers who instantly
responded by calling him
general mum a caged simpleton and an old
granny for refusing to voice his stance
on the issues
other attacks decried him as a sort of
backwoods yahoo who would be content to
live in a log cabin drinking cider and
collecting his pension
what they didn't know is that harrison's
wig party would cease on this imagery
making the log cabin hard cider and
objectively dope coonskin hat the symbol
of his campaign
ironically harrison was actually born
for a wealthy family and lived in a
mansion
anyway intent on defending himself and
his physical strength harrison embarked
on a tour around the country
holding raucous cider drenched rallies
to prove how tough he was
still he at least pretended to have some
reservations in one speech
harrison confessed that this campaigning
violated his sense of propriety
and that he feared he was establishing a
dangerous precedent
he told crowds that he wasn't there to
campaign but this didn't stop him from
decrying his opponents
basically the first real campaign was
kind of just the result of one man's
refusal to uh
look like he was sitting at home
twiddling his thumbs in the process
harrison who was maligned for being the
then oldest candidate at 68 years of age
re-branded himself as a 19th century
all-american bro
this is what jameson calls the first
example of image advertising in
presidential campaigning
and after some exhausting mid-19th
century travel harrison won
intent on looking strong at the
inauguration ceremony he did not wear a
hat or a coat despite the
miserable weather because wearing a coat
is for sissies i guess
anyway he talked for two hours and got
seriously sick though most probably from
drinking contaminated washington dc
water
anyway he died just four weeks after
which like
bummer but harrison's log cabin
revolution didn't change everything so
fast for the next three elections
publicly taking to the stump
that is traveling the nation giving the
same speech over and over again
was actually considered a bad move the
only candidate to repeat harrison's
ballsy antics was with general winfield
scott
who earns democratic disdain for
encouraging man worship
when he lost everyone extolled his
victorious opponent franklin pierce and
his silence
and blamed scott for being a
blabbermouth this continued from 1860 to
1872
during which democrats kept stumping and
kept losing
however image advertising was still
evolving you couldn't go anywhere
without seeing a photograph of abe
lincoln's face
but the guy was nowhere to be found he
didn't write letters or make speeches or
participate in debates
those famous lincoln douglas debates
were actually over a senate seat which
was a little more kosher
anyway the curse of the stump loomed
large but at the same time
people wanted to hear their guy talk so
in the late 19th century
we saw a kind of uneasy transition into
the front porch speech
where several candidates like james
garfield or benjamin harrison
invited supporters over to watch them
speak from their house which wasn't
technically campaigning because you were
just being a polite host okay
like how it isn't technically assault if
i swing this bat wildly around and you
just happen to be in front of me which
is to say
it totally is and so slowly it becomes
increasingly less taboo for the
presidential candidate to speak for
themselves
but this modest style of campaigning
would get seriously undermined with one
william jennings bryan
former democratic congressman and
renowned orator
ryan never won the presidency but he'd
go down in history for revolutionizing
the modern campaign
a pioneer of the whistle stop tour which
used the fledgling railway system to
traverse a nation
brian embarked on four big trips giving
stump speeches at nearly
every railway stop his regimen of 600
passionate speeches in three months
reached by some estimates
5 million americans meanwhile his
opponent william mckinley
stuck to the chiller front porch
campaign while letting a sprawling
network of surrogates do most of the
campaigning for him
at the same time brian encountered
pushback from republicans who criticized
him for begging for the presidency as a
[ __ ] might beg for a pie
but brian knew he was playing to his
strengths as an incredibly effective
orator
known for rousing crowds to mania with
lines like you shall not crucify mankind
on a cross of gold
though brian lost he marked an important
moment in campaign history
when according to ellis and dedrick the
nominee was expected to be the primary
spokesman and central figure of the
campaign
this is the world we exist in today of
course but with this change came another
development
the rise of the personality or more
specifically the packaged personality
for candidates
and as speeches would start moving from
stump tours to your home
via radio and television people began to
care more and more about what their
favorite candidate was like
are they a huge weeb can i have a beer
with them do i get the vague sense that
they moonlight as a serial killer
franklin roosevelt like his uncle teddy
seemed to recognize this instinctively
and his ability to project warmth
likeability and supreme competence in
newsreels and over the radio
encouraged a nation while an incumbent
president campaigning for re-election
was still generally frowned upon
fdr for the most part spun himself more
diplomatically as a president of the
whole people
and got away with it of course roosevelt
was consciously doing some major
image advertising a la or boy harrison
the guy was savvy about the way he
packaged his own brand
always campaigning with his same
cigarette holder jaunty top hat
ponce and smile he effortlessly exuded a
compelling personality
equal parts jokester and calming voice
of reason stricken with polio
roosevelt was determined to portray
physical strength in the media
and developed all kinds of sneaky ways
to hide his paralysis
in his political career he'd pull stunts
to emphasize his strength
like flying to the national convention
to accept his candidacy
back when air travel was dangerous and
embarking on railroad tours where he was
able to appear to be standing on his own
while secretly being supported by a
steel bar overall
roosevelt used campaigning to prove he
was presidential both in its assumed
norms of health
and this whole personality driven i'm a
man shtick
of course we can see similar themes
rippling into today
when our current president works
overtime to stress his vigor and health
after contracting a deadly virus
i feel much better now so in some ways
the quest to prove yourself tough
healthy and manly
has been something of a constant but a
lot else has changed
specifically the rhetoric of how
personality is conveyed but if you want
to understand how our personality driven
elections have become a non-stop blitz
of tv
ads and dumb optics we need to talk
about dwight d eisenhower the first tv
candidate
now it's not that eisenhower was just
the first candidate to widely campaign
on tv
it's that he handed over a big chunk of
his strategy to admin
it was 1951 and though he was the most
popular man in america
eisenhower had no government experience
outside the military
and so sought to convey legitimacy
instead of counting on the lengthy
speeches of yore
he hired admin to produce several dozen
short tv spots of him
answering advertiser penned questions
recited by average americans
with advertiser penned answers to say
these were light on policy
or any substance for that matter is an
understatement
eisenhower initially worried that these
ads were undignified
but was convinced to give it a shot at
the admins behest
he removed his glasses changed his
clothes and talked faster
in this way according to scholar john e
hollitz eisenhower's admin had
accomplished the first successful
attempt to sell a presidential candidate
by employing the same techniques that
sold soap and toothpaste
now if you preferred a less made-for-tv
candidate you might have fancied the
hyper-intellectual adlay stevenson
he was called an egghead for being a
smartypants who talked fancy
his beautiful rhetoric was of course
irrelevant because he looked hella
uncomfortable on screen
struggling with the teleprompter and
flashing an awkward smile stevenson
loathed appearing in political ads
considering them too short to fully
express his ideas
and let's just say his performances
didn't have that special pizazz
which the eisenhower administration has
been
giving away he's been described as a
19th century style presidential
candidate
who unlike his opponent refused to be
packaged or phony
while republicans spent somewhere around
1 million dollars on tv ads
democrats spent just 77 000 stevenson
ran against eisenhower
and lost twice demonstrating that
packaging your personality was now
paramount
the intimacy of television demanded that
the candidate be personable
showing empathy and likability above all
it solidified the importance of tv
friendly catch lines
over any meaningful engagement with the
issues and
we're still feeling the effects today so
to win the presidency
now you had to be palatable on
television you see what's coming
after all what's more palatable than a
goddamn celebrity
enter jfk an incredibly charismatic
politician who spent five years building
a grassroots operation
and giving speeches to gain popularity
if eisenhower was the first tv candidate
kennedy was the first candidate actually
made for tv
able to give short decisive answers with
profound eloquence
and he knew it packaging his persona as
that of the youthful
vital compassionate strong leader
kennedy had this thing in the bag
as his father put it we're going to sell
jack like snowflakes
it was kennedy who would invite his
opponent richard nixon to the first ever
presidential debate
taking place on millions of tv screens
it wasn't even a fair fight
the youthful and aesthetically blessed
kennedy spent weeks tanning and wore a
bit of stage makeup
which nixon refused appearing pale
nervous and sweaty in a suit that
blended into the background
there's lore that radio listeners
believed nixon won and tv viewers
believed kennedy had
but not really enough data to back it up
still
what we do know is that the debate was
so decisive in boosting kennedy's
campaign eventually to victory
that no sitting president agreed to
participate in debates for another 16
years
the presidency had now in many ways
firmly become a bonafide popularity
contest
once a candidate becomes a packaged
personality it becomes very easy to
become obsessed with anything that might
tarnish that packaging
candidates began to see if they were
likeable enough with hyperspecific
polling data
the rise of this data and the weakening
of party power did something specific to
our politics
as outlined by sidney blumenthal in his
1980 book
the permanent campaign starting with
lyndon johnson blumenthal explained
we saw the act of governance become a
perpetual effort to get re-elected
with the combined use of political
strategy and image making
as blumenthal writes permanent
campaigning remakes government into an
instrument designed to sustain an
elected official's popularity
essentially this meant the line between
campaigning and governing
started to disappear as presidents made
choices and conveyed messages
increasingly based on the reaction it
would incur from the american people
according to scholar hugo heclo the
strategy of permanent campaigning
crystallized under richard nixon
who employed unprecedented white house
use of public opinion polling
political consultants and comprehensive
media strategies
and like in pursuit of a second term to
those who hated him heklow writes
the man's whole political existence
seemed a shabby and conniving permanent
campaign
this arguably can be seen in his
inconsistency on civil rights
when courting northern black votes in
1960 he seemed generally committed to
the cause
equal rights for all our citizens why
must we vigorously defend them
first because it is right and just when
courting southern white votes in 1972
he was against laws that would further
integrate schools i do not believe that
busing to achieve racial
balance is in the interest of better
education and
by admission of his own campaign invoked
racist anxieties with dog whistle
rhetoric
by 1968 you can't say that hurts your
backfire so you say stuff like
force bussing states lights and all that
stuff
the permanent campaign and paramount
importance of political celebrity
continued with literal hollywood
political celebrity ronald reagan's rise
to power
after easily beating incumbent jimmy
carter reagan did something unexpected
he brought all of his campaign's best
posters media masters and tacticians
with him
to the white house there they worked
throughout his presidency
using the same campaign techniques to
address and win the approval of the
american people
as a 1981 new york times article put it
for the reagan white house
every night is election night on
television their obsessive strategizing
was why according to the times
reagan had such stunning success in
shaping public opinion
of course with constant campaigning
comes constant image making
reagan used his first term to cultivate
his own mythology
that meant endless strategic photo ops
showing him riding horses
chopping wood pumping iron like many a
candidate before him
the oldest president no doubt felt
pressure to portray himself as a dude
who does
dude-like things while reagan had
previously run on a reasonably robust
platform of reducing inflation and taxes
his 1984 campaign was according to a
republican strategist
virtually issueless his ads peddled
largely in image-based patriotism with
nary a policy discussion to be found
this is when that song i'm proud to be
an american became something of an
anthem for fifty percent of the country
and a terrible ear worm for future
generations
the phenomenon of the permanent campaign
can be traced in each subsequent
presidency
at the same time heckler notes the
politics of permanent campaigning
and the media's consequent framing of
every day as a political battle that is
to be won or lost
prioritizes dramatic conflict over
meaningful debate about the issues
over the next 30 years the permanent
campaign became an
ongoing quest to seem presidential aka
likeable and popular
as candidates and presidents alike
turned increasingly to entertainment
venues like talk shows to establish
their home spun likability
once elected they continue to
re-establish that likability
over and over and over again how does it
feel having a three-inch vertical
it's a three-inch horizontal george bush
took 416 trips
frequently to swing states in his first
three years
while bill clinton even created a voter
poll to decide where he should go on
vacation
so the line between governing and
campaigning continued to erode
all the while more and more money would
continue to pour into
the political game of marketing charisma
particularly after the citizens united
decision
which allowed for limitless money to
flood into elections
at the same time as the media
increasingly focused on the most
contentious aspects of politicking
rather than actual policy issues
negative ads about the other candidate's
personal suckiness
dominated by 2012 only 14.3 percent of
ads were positive
according to a university of mississippi
study which brings us to today
when presidents must seem presidential
but no one can seem to agree with that
means
while eschewing many norms of running a
campaign donald trump is paradoxically
the natural extension of years of
increased obsession with presidential
personality
the former apprentice star has spent
years preoccupied with his own celebrity
crafting an image as a shrewd
businessman unencumbered by any rules
at the same time democratic attacks of
him center around how unpresidential his
personality is
and of course trump is the embodiment of
the permanent candidate
filing his paperwork for re-election the
day he took office
and continuing rallies throughout his
tenure and a pandemic
by this point we'd all become so used to
the permanent campaign
that it took his extreme approach to
make anybody really notice something
strange was going on
after one more campaign season that
seems to stretch on for eternity
and a series of debates that could only
be described generously as
hell on earth were you sure we're left
wondering if keeping up to date on
campaign news is making us less
rather than more informed maybe our
fixation on the personality and personal
proclivities of any individual candidate
hasn't just become inane but dangerous
when we are obsessed with someone's
likeability
we can find ourselves lulled into
supporting the most grotesque policies
political campaigning began in the first
place because people wanted to know
where their candidates stood on the
issues
it's devolved to the point where
candidate positions often feel more
inscrutable after watching them debate
or in an ad
or on a talk show as much reporting as
there is about the candidates
and their presidentialness it can feel
like there's very little
actually being taught or learned but who
knows
maybe we're all becoming savvy to this
maybe there will be some magical
backlash when people start speculating
about the 2024 election three weeks from
now
or maybe we can stop the weird
personality worship of politicians
one can only drain but what do you guys
think
is the american campaign cycle just
proof of how good we are at democracy
or is it a literal scourge in our nation
and also
raising my blood pressure for no reason
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support
slam that subscribe button like it's
your worst political enemy
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you